yet another new twist in the College
Admission scandal Lori locklins daughter
Olivia Jade is reportedly furious with
her parents and thinks they ruined her
career she has since been dropped by
major brands including Sephora and
Tracey Mae and according to sources she
didn't even want to go to college but
her parents forced her to instead she
just wanted to continue her path as a
social-media influencer and admits all
of these developments there's apparently
a new term for this type of parent
they're being dubbed snow pile parents
because they try to clear obstacles out
of the way of their kids even as adults
okay so Dana apparently you have a
theory I just have a theory that this is
all a plan like they had a family
meeting and they said okay you should go
out and say that you're really mad that
you never really wanted to go to college
and then when when the dust blows over
but when it all gets sort of resolved
they are going to have a reality show
and it's going to be something where
they get a lot of money to talk about
they're like dysfunctional family and
how rich they are and how they didn't
what do they want to go to college I
just think there's gonna be a show you
know what's interesting about that
though is given the trouble the parents
are in there will be such a disgorge
'men of funds and finances and wage
garnishment from the feds if they if
this continues down that line then
whatever money they make from that is
discouragement a word I've never heard
that word yeah yes yeah you're welcome
okay gourds mint don't fan it what would
you do if none of your girls or both of
your girls came home and they were like
dad we just want to be social media
influencers we don't want to go to
college would you say I changed the will
I'd change it right there and then and
that's what this younger girl is running
up against if you try to emancipate
yourself or try to bad-mouth your mom
and dad in the press that will gets
changed like in a heartbeat so I'd be
very careful because she's gonna be in
the poorhouse if she disrespects her
parents like that my parents were the
opposite of snowplow parents I talked
about the other day how they made me do
these outdoor wilderness adventure
survival schools I had to sleep in
lightning storms we carried a kid out in
a stretcher made from tree branches
because he shattered his knee I mean I
went through so much hell and and
heartbreak in these will
adventure survival schools they put me
on a solo they gave me three matches and
said I'll see in three days and I had to
survive by myself I had severe sunburn
we had ice picks that we climb up on the
mountain with we had a ten mile fun run
at the end of the trip it was horrible I
feel like you're basically saying Boy
Scouts was hell no it was a lot more
than that how dare you okay
Greg I'm sure you feel strongly well
okay so I'm not sure if this story is
true because it begins with sources say
but if true two greatest words in
journalism history the daughter is
absolutely right in this she figured out
that she didn't need college and she
looked around and she saw that she could
pursue a career in social media uh if
this was my kid I would have been so
grateful that I didn't have to pay
$100,000 a year and that this kid is
already making a living off other dumb
kids on social media I mean I think that
I think she's absolutely right that she
had the right way and her parents were
forcing an old idea on her but she knew
better she knew I'm not maybe I don't
need college maybe I'm not smart enough
to do college maybe I could just fleece
people on Instagram and become super
rich and then I'm like I'm thinking like
I want to have a kid like that you want
your kid to fleece people your kids
aren't there so accomplished you feel I
mean are you Republicans you mean agree
a little bit with what Greg saying or do
you feel like you know a degree is
valuable no matter what and I should
always be I think I think I love
education I think it teaches critical
thinking teaches you how to debate
teaches you we were talking about speech
in the previous segment I think you
should hear people have different
opinions and have different experience
others think that's that's the world we
live in and it's good for you but I will
say in this case I think these are like
candy cane kids they're melting in the
rain and I think they are spoiled rich
kids to no end and their parents the
parents had their own reason for one in
getting a college which i think is
status but even if the kid let's say you
you know kid I want you to go to college
because I believe in college why weren't
they satisfied with Layton the kid go to
a college that the kid actually could
merit earn admission to apparently that
wasn't good enough for them because of
the social status out in Hollywood or
whatever to me this is a corruption of
values and morals I just don't approve
of it I so I don't think the kid is
right I think the kid is vacuous and
self-serving but she knows like it don't
that's what's great she knows she's
vacuous but we just want to cure that
wouldn't you want to help your kid
[Laughter]